[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning
pressure is mounting for a new
investigation into the death of a man
after an encounter with police in
Colorado last August according to his
family 23 year old Elijah McClain was
out buying iced tea when he was stopped
by three officers after someone had
called 911 claim was wearing a ski mask
and acting weird quote waving his arms
around within 15 minutes he had been put
in a chokehold and injected with a
powerful sedative our lead national
correspondent David Begg know is
following the case stop right there stop
stop stop stop I have a right to stop
you because you're being suspicious huh
relax
I'm going home relax or I'm going to
have to change this situation
the District Attorney investigating the
case says that Elijah McClain dismissed
the officers requests for him to stop
the 23 year olds family says he was just
walking home he was listening to music
when Aurora Colorado police approached
him last August the DA says mcclain was
carrying a plastic bag when police tried
to pat him down and he refused he's then
heard pleading with the police as they
tackle him and use a chokehold on him
paramedics later arrived at the scene a
medic gave McLean ketamine to sedate him
McLain was taken to the hospital three
days later he was pronounced brain dead
ten months after McLean's death more
than two million people have signed a
petition calling on Colorado officials
to fire the three officers involved so
far the Aurora Police Department has
declined CBS News his request for
comment da Dave Young is the one who
decided not to charge the officers were
the actions of the officers justified
legally yes mr. young do you believe
there was a moment in this where the
officers could have de-escalated the
situation absolutely a hundred percent
they could have done a million things
differently he didn't need to die
and the fact that he died does not
warrant the basis for criminal charges
in the body camera video cops are heard
saying that McLain tried to take one of
their guns he went for his gun Mari
Neumann represents McLean's family don't
you think if he really had grabbed
someone's gun we would see fingerprints
that had been lifted from the gun did
you find any evidence that corroborates
the officer who said he reached for the
gun I had no evidence to contradict that
Jeannine McLean is Elijah's mother they
they're bullies with badges he wanted to
know people here was a massage therapist
he not only healed others that he healed
himself he was able to accept love and
give other various forms according to
the district attorney's report the
medical examiner was unable to determine
a cause of death
it is important to note that walking
around with a ski mask is not illegal
and when you go back to the 911 call the
caller didn't say that Elijah did
anything illegal he said hey there's a
guy wearing a mask he kind of is waving
his hand seems a little strange you
might want to check it out he says he
might be a good guy might be a bad guy
and so Galle when the police responded
instead of observing instead of watching
hanging back for a bit the police moved
in immediately to stop him and
everything went south from there